みんな聞いてますねさあゲンネモ
うんこまんぬ痛くなくなってきたぞ
こちらはず者です配球でかなりあばらがよくなってきました完璧になるまでもう少々お
待ち下さいませ結局ねあの俺ね叫ばないといけない人間だと思った上で今回一緒に動画
を撮っていくお友達がこちらアップヌードをカップ麺のなイメージですね
こちらで今ですね見てパッケージからもこぼれ落ちてるんだけども謎肉が増量されて
いるのにこのな
ずいぶん何かと言いますと知ってる人もいると思うんですけどモトカップヌードルの
表面上にへ人が卵とが色々あるんですけどその中でよくわかんね肉の塊みたいなかある
んですよこれが謎肉ってられてるんですけどもそれがちょっと人気で安全間も似たよう
な謎肉が増量してるカップでの言われてるんですの爆売れして今回それの中にメイクと
かよくわかんないですけどもたとえ謎肉が増量されているカップ麺が出てるっていう
流れなんですよこのビッグウェーブに
よろし金やけどちょっとたくさん買ってみましたちょっと謎肉どれくらい入ってるか見
てみましょう
少なくに吹くないよ
待って待って経済学類やでめっちゃ入っていう想定だったので超少ないですこれやばっ
空されてんのあー1曲リップをパンセッチェーンで大変は1個しか入って ai 約
増えてるのかなもともと夫助けないんかなちょっとわかんないとけど今回の企画はらず
に行くぞー
量と聞いてカップヌードロー買って食べようとして開けてみたらまず肉増量の増量の量
があまりに多すぎて食べ続けると中身が全部謎肉だったドッキリやっていこうと思い
ます
b はっはっはっ入って来てて青すると思うよまあ謎肉増量中なんですよいままあ謎肉
ゾード中やってだけでなずに行け増量のカップ麺食った画像良心的で場合が全部謎に
食ってるトってなんですよ関西書士の湯中ばあさんが来てるんでえそんな換算
ユーチューバーの彼にこの時をしてまーなんて帰ってくるかやってみようと思いますと
関西人
ブーバーしましょうウードゥー
10個挙げてこれぐらいしか積めませんでしたこれだけでさすがに勝つんでいっぱいに
するのはちょっときついねちょっともうちょっと書いたしてきまーす付く姓を履いて外
で追加で20個買いました
20これの3倍んああ
びっくりだしてみます
ん
me
入ってだけでさんずっぱこ分の謎肉取り出しました
結構量があるんですけれどもこうどうなんだろうなこれ遊戯が膨れがちょっとわかん
ないです1体よりに入れてみましょう
ば昆明
wh
一応中身綺麗にしました果たして夏に切れてどれぐらい膨れる重ね入れていきますね
結構ここ大事ってはこれでは見えなかったらさらに謎肉買わなきゃいけなくなるからね
はあああああ
ちょうどいいすごいめっちゃちょうど綺麗ですめっちゃ計算がうまくいってた30個で
ぴったりです今後のと比べてはめちゃくちゃ同じような量だと思いますて the
すでに開けた瞬間船便に降ったら信じられないところで後てな事がエビとか持ち出して
それっぽくしておきますこれだったらマジでバレると思うんだよ中身は全部肉なんだ
けども
パッと見普通にマジで車
演じちゃうくらいの感じや移動でしょまあ加えて混ぜて示せるかなと思います
こっからだんですけどもこのままだと早速にバレるねこの2実はでねネッツを与えると
またくっつくんですよ
これドッキリでを使えるんで皆さん是非覚えておいてください
[音楽]
でレッシャースタッフ
あっはぁ完璧です
ベリーながらターゲットよねなんか適当な企画でカップヌードル食べますみたいなこと
を言ってあげたら大増量すごいなということになってお湯を注いで食べたら全部謎肉
だったドッキリ捧げていこうと思いますではターゲット new
ちょっ
[音楽]
ん
うわぁ杉ケ瀬よ
いきますよはいこんにちはさあ
ふわってくる全然そんなん言われちゃうのーいうこっちにシュっぽいどうしてますか
患者2人社長とどうも書いたです
入ってでカイトさん関西はですよね関数生まれというわけですね
居間で寝カチッ
雑用してでカップヌードルの謎肉どれくら
入っているのかちょっと対処を開けてるかなるほどやってみたいと思いますそれは
関西人どうこうの問題じゃないけどまつげないですでちなみに負けたらどうなるんです
か
負けたら1年間アゾニック性格です
嘘ですさっそくやっていきましょうやってみましょうはい q から10個
どっちかにします増量なので服は9個なるほどなるほど
はいありました太秦垣内久野ちゃんですね入っ
早速描けてみてください入ってはできますはい
えっ今宵ねすごい多いだこれ緑で分かる曲じゃない奴と食べてみないと何が悪いか
わかんないんで
パッ親指できますっこっちはそれくらいかもしれねぇあ確かにねもう謎肉増量のと io
これからねそうカップヌードルさんっはいで3分立ちましたはい
お買い得の予想は9個表面だけて超えてるやんいやダマダマ案外救護かもしれないんだ
よ
これはいくつたけど場合それが一番底を持って
面だったらネップカメはずですあなるほどそこ柄につかメーカーによってうわっ
神社主人人スペシャルチカチカ as でいけますよ
ちょっと思って
んですけどっ
エペでフェール月
あ謎肉敷かれん
me
ana あった
関西の方にやるとどういう帰ってくべか貼ってああああ名前でございなボケ様ここに
食べさせていただきます
it 9型
テイク2 el